you
hello everyone and welcome to today's
Podcast integrating hematology and
coagulation results to enhance diagnosis
presented by dr. Larry Smith manager
medical and scientific affairs
hematology Abbott Diagnostics
I am Alexis Krause of lab rats and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lab birds and
sponsored by Abbott Diagnostics now
let's get started before I begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click on the send button once
there's many of your questions as we had
time for at the end of the presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the
support tab button found at the top
right corner of the presentation window
or report your problems by clicking on
the answer a question box located on the
far left of your screen this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits I'd like to now introduce our
presenter dr. Larry Smith dr. Larry
Smith received his doctorate in
biological sciences from Fordham
University Bronx New York and completed
his certificate in molecular laboratory
Diagnostics at Michigan State University
he completed his postdoctoral studies in
gene therapy and experimental
hematopoietic at Columbia University
College of Physicians and Surgeons New
York and was a research fellow in
immunology at Fordham University in
addition dr. Smith has a Master of
Science and medical biology and a
Bachelor of Science in French and
biology he holds multiple board
certificates and has published numerous
peer-reviewed articles abstract reviews
and monographs his research interests
include the board Tori test development
for hemostasis and coagulation HBC
therapeutic applications and flow
cytometry for a complete biography and
dr. Smith please click on his photo in
the top left corner of your screen
welcome dr. Smith you may now begin your
presentation
hello I'd like to welcome everyone to
today's lecture on integrating human
ecology and coagulation results to
enhance diagnosis this program is
sponsored by and on behalf of adder
diagnostics and the content of this
presentation is consistent with all
applicable FDA requirements hematology
and coagulation testing represent a
large majority of tests that are
frequently performed in the core
laboratory now in some laboratories the
hematology lab and the coagulation lab
are separate and in some cases where the
two labs are in the same physical
location we don't always integrate the
results from both areas when we are
analyzing very complex cases so what I'd
like to show you today is how we can
improve management of patients with
chemical logic disorders through
integrating results from human ecology
and coagulation and I'd like to do this
by describing three disease states that
are better managed by the combination of
coagulation and hematology results so
I'm going to present three cases one
will be acute promyelocytic leukemia one
chronic lymphocytic leukemia and one on
from bursitis thrombotic
thrombocytopenic purpura by way of
introduction hematology and coagulation
laboratories perform a wide variety of
specialized in routine tests for
screening diagnosis treatment and
prognosis of human logic disorders and
very often of many of the abnormalities
of in hematology testing can have a
significant impact on coagulation
testing and what we find is that when
physicians actually combine the results
from both of these areas it can actually
improve and aid positions in making more
rapid diagnosis and even initiate
therapies much sooner in their patients
so let's start with the case of a
patient who presents with a presumptive
diagnosis of acute promyelocytic
leukemia Anakin
disseminated intravascular coagulopathy
or di C APL was actually described in
1957 in a patient presented with a
severe bleeding tendencies and these
were fibrinolytic in nature and an
increase in promyelocytes in both the
peripheral blood smear and in the bone
marrow this patient also had a rapidly
deteriorating of course if this was
actually described by dr. leap Hillestad
in 1957 and this disease is
characterized by a balanced reciprocal
translocation between chromosomes 15 and
17 it's also characterized by the World
Health Organization as AML or acute
myelogenous leukemia with recurrent
genetic abnormalities and that would be
a translocation between chromosomes 15
and 17 and this involves a team called
the retinoic acid receptor gene that
gets
juxtaposed next to the PML gene now
under the old French American British
classification APL is actually called m3
in these patients we see an increase in
promyelocytes and maybe some blacks on
the peripheral blood smear and there is
this rapid fatal course with a high
incidence of early interacting bleeding
in terms of some of the frequencies of
APL it's relatively rare and it
comprises about seven to eight percent
of adult AML cases it's usually seen in
middle-aged individuals with a median
age of 47 and occurs very rarely of
before the age of 20
the incidence again is slightly higher
in males than in females
turning to the pathogenesis of APL the
defining abnormality is the
translocation between chromosome 15 and
17 that involves the two genes that I
mentioned earlier the PML gene as well
as the retinoic acid receptor gene in
normal individuals the PML gene is a is
a genus
and so broken division and even in
apoptosis the retinoic acid receptor
gene is actually encodes a nuclear
hormone receptor transcription factor
that promotes the expression of various
genes after binding to retinoic acid so
when the actual translocation occurs
what we see is that the PML gene here
located on the long arm of chromosome 15
and the retinoic acid receptor gene
located here on chroma on the long arm
of chromosome 17 actually the two genes
get juxtaposed next to each other so
this then results in the formation of a
fusion protein or chimeric protein and
this protein of actually results of in
the deactivation or it leads to a
transcriptional repression and a risk of
differentiation of the promyelocytes so
the pro-rata sites get stuck in the
promyelocytes stage they don't continue
on in their differentiation pathway now
the diagnosis of APL is time critical so
this is because hemorrhage is a major
cause of death in these patients these
patients do present with di c most often
and the di c in these patients is caused
it directly and indirectly by the
abnormal promyelocytes if you look at
the diagram on the right here's an
abnormal APL cell and located on the
surface are a number of molecules of
tissue factor so there's an an
overexpression of tissue factor on the
surfaces of these cells this tissue
factor is capable of activating the
coagulation cascade and this would lead
to a tissue factor induced disseminated
intravascular coagulopathy at the same
time looking at the image at the bottom
of the screen again we have an abnormal
APL cell and located on the surface is
an increase in an x + 2 and the Nexen 2
has been described this being an active
fibrinolysis so with these patients we
have we have di C that comes from an
increase in tuition factor and we also
have activation of the fibrinolytic
system that would cause for an increase
in bleeding as well so as a
life-threatening coagulopathy it would
require prompt diagnosis and recognition
of this coagulation defect so patients
with APL when they present with this
coagulopathy addition always be treated
at a medical emergency now in addition
to this abnormality within the
coagulation cascade itself of the
abnormal promyelocytes
actually invade the bone marrow and this
then prevents the megakaryocytes from
releasing platelets so we have this
compounded condition of activation of
the coagulation cascade with a failure
to produce platelets so this all of
these combined we have an increased risk
for bleeding in these patients
now some APL patients there has been a
description of dramatic manifestation
that can occur with APL as well so
what's the typical of a flowchart when a
patient comes in for testing for APL
well it starts with a presumptive
diagnosis that's based on a clinical
presentation and patient history this
would then be followed by a CBC and
differential and routine coagulation
screening the information that we get
just from these two types of assays
would be enough to confirm the
presumptive diagnosis later blood will
be sent on these patients for
confirmatory diagnosis and this would
include the bone marrow biopsy
fluorescent in situ hybridization of
conventional karyotyping as well as flow
cytometry and then once these patients
are treated we can continuously monitor
these patients using the CBC and
differential along with routine
coagulation screening
so what would what would some of the
results look like in the hematology lab
in the patient who presents with APL
well if you look at the table that we
have here we notice that we have an
elevated WBC counter this would be
consistent with a patient who presents
with an undiagnosed APL in addition we
know that many of these patients who
present leukemia have anemia and so here
we would notice that the RBC count the
immigrant and the hematocrit are all
decreased and this would be consistent
with the picture of anemia and then
another result that's very important in
the human ecology lab would be the
platelet count here we see the platelet
count is decreased and this too would be
consistent with bleeding now if we look
toward the middle of the slide here we
see an image of two different histograms
and these histograms were very based on
the type of hematology analyzer that you
use but what you would expect from such
a histogram would be at least several
populations of lymphocytes and monocytes
and granulocytes and we would also see a
population of abnormal cells that would
be present as well again this will
differ based on the types of analyzers
you have but it would be a signal to
trigger the opportunity to let the
operator know that there is an
abnormality in addition to the abnormal
numbers that we see in addition there
are a number of flags that may be
generated on our theme ecology analyzers
and these flags differ based on the
analyzer but one could expect to see a
blast flag or an immature cell flag one
might expect to see some kind of flag
that that indicates immature
granulocytes and even a flag that might
indicate a left shift again these will
vary from instrument to instrument but
some type of flag would be their picture
to the operator to maybe request a
review smear and in this case of review
smear was done and what you can see on
the right side of the smear are two
cells these are abnormal provirus sites
and these cells are
characteristic of what was on the actual
smear these this actually represented
the majority of the cells that were on
this year what you notice when you look
at these cells is that there's a high NC
ratio of presence of nuclear life
present within the cells there is an
abundance of gradual granules that are
located in the cytoplasm the nucleus has
a fine chromatin pattern and often many
of these larger granules in the
cytoplasm may call s to form our rods a
manuals account was done and in this
particular patient there were 85%
promyelocytes 1% blasts and then 9%
lymphocytes 3% monos and 2% eosinophils
what would you expect in the coagulation
laboratory well looking at this table we
see we have some screening tests the pta
PTT the fibrinogen in the d-dimer and
what you'll notice is that the PT is
elevated the a PTT is elevated the
d-dimer is elevated and the fibrinogen
is decreased now when you take all of
these numbers of all of these results
when you take these into consideration
this would appear to be some type of
consumption that's occurring and this
would be consistent with di see we can
also go back to the previous slide and
note that the quickly count was
decreased as well and all of this would
fit the picture when you see results
like this it is necessary to
differentiate between di see vs. TTP and
verses liver disease and I'll show you a
slide later on and to show you exactly
how we can do that when we are testing
patients for di see there are two types
of tests that really need to be done the
first isn't up in the coagulation
laboratory the first is a screening
assay in the screening assay like the PT
or the APD T would simply show you that
if the results are elevated we simply
show you that consumption is occurring
we also need a test that we
demonstrate of thrombin generation along
with fibrin degradation and this is
where the elevated d9 Rovers come into
play so we've met both of the character
both of the requirements for for
identifying v.i.c in the collaboration
laboratory so as you can see integrating
the results from the hematology and
coagulation laboratories provides
diagnosis within minutes and it improved
patient management and so we have a
little graphic here just to show you
that the test that we do in hematology
would consist of the WBC count and we
also visualize the increase
promyelocytes we also have
thrombocytopenia from our platelet count
and then we have anemia from our red
cells and hemoglobin hematocrit
parameters in addition we also see the
coagulation we would have our elevated
d-dimer elevated of PT and a PTT those
would show us that consumptions going on
with di c and we have our hypo
fibrinogen emia with our low fibrinogen
results in this patient
additionally for confirming the
diagnosis of APL certainly one would
send a bone marrow aspirate to the lab
along with flow cytometry and as you can
see from this particular image on the
left of this bone marrow Speier has is
full of promyelocytes so this would be
consistent with the diagnosis and when
we look at the flow cytometry we have
c-13 CB 33 Stevi 1 1 7 and
myeloperoxidase are all positive and in
patients with APL cd34 is usually
negative along with HL s HL ADR so this
would then be further confirmation that
would that we're dealing with a case of
APL additional risk factors can be seen
in patients with APL that require
monitoring and these would include
things like the cytokine release
syndrome and this is this is a syndrome
that occurs in patients or receive
differentiation therapy this causes
these promyelocytes to release a lot of
cytokines and these cytokines have been
associated with activating the
coagulation cascade of we can monitor a
therapy in the cytokine release syndrome
through various chemical tests such as
the potassium phosphate calcium and uric
acid another risk factor would be the
hyper leukocytosis and of course we
would use the CBC and differential to
monitor how well we are improving the
type of leukocytosis and then finally
bleeding as we said was a real problem
in APL and often this bleeding can be
intracranial bleeding or even bleeding
into the lungs and certainly the routine
coagulation test would help us in terms
of monitoring the the progress in these
patients so the integration of these
results contributes to the improved
monitoring of these patients and it
allows physicians to treat them more
effectively
so let's now turn and look at another
case this would be another leukemia this
would be chronic lymphocytic leukemia so
chronic will defeat the chronic
lymphocytic leukemia is actually had
acquired model corner disorder that's
characterized by a progressive
accumulation of functionally and
competence of lymphocytes it's
considered the most common form of
leukemia in adults in Western countries
and it's extremely rare in Asian
countries when we look at the incidence
of CLL it's of the incidence is slightly
higher in males and females the ratios
1.7 males or one female and of the
disease primarily affects the elderly
the median age is sevens is around 72
years of age there are some cases of
familial of CLL and here the median age
is a little bit lower at 58 years of age
but these cases are somewhat rare but
they do exist and then finally patients
who do develop CL CLL actually have a
fairly long lifespan these patients can
live anywhere from five to ten years ex
diagnosis there are some reported cases
of patients who may die within two to
three years but this is always due to
complications that develop within CH CLL
and so these cases are not really as as
common as the cases of CLL all patients
actually live a much longer time frame
some additional characteristics if we
look at the pathophysiology of CF CLL we
find that most of the cells are called B
cells and the Gandy cells are arrested
in their B cell differentiation pathway
all of these cells have a B cell surface
antigen these antigens range from city
19 to 20 to 1 and CD 23 in normal
individuals but in CLL of the cd20 is
dim the other markers are still there
but the CD 20 is dim
now these patients also express an
aberrant T cell marker and this would be
C D Phi
so we're going to get a V cell marker
and T cell marker on the very same cell
so this would be an average
co-expression when we look in the
clinical diagnosis as required for CLL
of course 5,000 B lymphocytes per
microliter and this has to be over a
prolonged period of at least three
months duration there are a number of
genetic abnormalities that are
associated with CLL of the most common
genetic abnormality is a deletion in
chromosome 13 and anywhere from 50 to 60
percent of the cases will have this
particular deletion these are the
patients who actually have a longer
lifespan of once they've been diagnosed
there are some additional mutations that
can occur and when patients present with
these mutations the disease is much
harder to to manage so what would a
patient with clo look like in the
laboratory and so this slide shows you
two different patients in the very top
box we have one patient and in the
bottom box we have a different patient
and so what we would see in the
hematology lab of course would be an
elevated white cell count of one of
these cases you see that is 66,000 and
the second case it's 71 thousand again
these patients will present with anemia
and so as you can see in both of these
cases there is a slight decrease in the
RBC count the hemoglobin and the
hematocrit which would be consistent
with that anemia now in CLL deplete
accounts and be variable and in both of
these cases there is a normal platelet
count one set hundred and seventy nine
thousand versus 220 mm looking toward
the middle of this line we see an
example of a histogram
now these histograms again will vary
depending on the analyzer that's being
used in the laboratory but we would
certainly see our ourselv clusters with
our lymphocyte population a monocyte
population and a granular flat
population but what you'll notice is
that this we have an increase in
lymphocytes in this particular cluster
you can
that it's quite long it encompasses a
much larger area and this would
represent the increased number of
absolute lymphocytes
if you're looking at the diagram at the
bottom at the lymphocyte population you
can see that instead of being really
tight it's a little bit spread out or a
little spread out going from left to
right and this would simply reflect the
variable sizes of the lymphocytes within
those populations so what we'll see in
these patients will be an elevated WBC
an increase in the absolute lymphocyte
count of depending on the analyzer that
you had there will be some type of
morphological flag this can range from a
black flag a variant lymphocyte flag and
other flags based on the analyzers that
you have to recognize for population and
often these patients will have on the
perfect blood smear smudge cells and on
some analyzers these what's much cells
may have an increase in fluorescence not
every analyzer will have these but we
can look for an increase in fluorescence
it and also identify some of these
smudge cells this is a peripheral blood
smear from a patient with CLL and what
you'll notice on the right is these
mature appearing lymphocytes they're
immuno incompetent it's somewhat of a
monotonous picture or by they all look
about the same and if you look at the
little insert to the further right
you'll see the presence of two SMUD
cells so these would be those fragile
lymphocytes that we were talking about
on the previous slide that might have an
increase in fluorescence on some
analyzers but certainly we would see
these on a peripheral blood smear as a
result of making the smear manually
since the cells are fragile looking at
these lymphocytes we noticed that the
chromatin pattern is somewhat chunky
it's been described as having a soccer
ball pattern or even a leopard skin
pattern again numerous too much cells
Wynwood
a peripheral blood smear and the RBC and
platelet morphology on this particular
slide is normal and that's really
consistent with CLL a confirmation of
CLL certainly can be made through flow
cytometry again you remember that the
surface antigen zone normal b-cells
consists of CD 19 20 21 and 23 and in
CLL the CD 20 is denn but you'll also
remember that I said there wasn't a
verdict spreche n' of a be so marker and
a t-cell marker so looking at the
histogram on the left right here we see
with CD 19 on the y-axis and CD 5 on the
x axis we see it a population of cells
that would Express both c 19 as well as
CD 5 so this would be characteristic of
CLL in addition these individuals will
express either capital light chain or
lambda light chain expression as well a
number of mechanisms have been described
to explain bleeding in patients with CLL
and so some of these mechanisms include
things like thrombocytopenia impaired
platelet function defects acquired von
Willebrand syndrome of some of these
patients develop inhibitors to various
factors in the coagulation cascade like
factor 8 or factor 9 and there are also
some therapy related mechanisms that
cause bleeding in these patients one of
these particular fair through therapy
related bleeding abnormalities that i'll
talk about deals with patients who take
a drug called a Bruton if a Bruton it
has been described as a transformative
therapy for patients with high-risk and
relaxed
refractory CLL and the taking the drug
by itself has a number of risk factors
such as infections that have been
described bacterial viral and fungal or
cytokine years have been described in
some of these patients as well when SCI
opinion
presenting these patients certainly we
can perform a CBC to identify which
lineage is decreased and we can also get
a white cell count along with a platelet
out for the thrombocytopenia and we can
define the parameters for the anemia
additionally bleeding is associated with
this particular drug and many of these
patients will present with low-grade
akibo season petechia and this actually
occurs in about 50% of these patients a
major hemorrhage has been reported in a
room anywhere from 1 to 9 percent and
about 6% of those were fatal bleeding
it's also recommended that when patients
are taken of this particular drug and
they're also taking an antiplatelet or
an anticoagulant therapy that they be
monitored for the risk of bleeding and
certainly the coagulation laboratory
comes into play in in this regard the
actual mechanism that's associated with
this particular drug in patients with
CLL is that this drug has been shown to
inhibit a number of kinase --is that are
present within the platelet so if you
think about the glycoproteins 6 receptor
on platelets will receive a signal this
signal will be generated through the
plate through the platelet and
ultimately result in platelet
aggregation of platelet adhesion and it
uses these kinase 'iz as it's being
generated it turns out that a Bruton
actually inhibits these kinase a--'s
such that the signal can no longer
regenerate it and this would affect the
ability of these platelets to aggregate
as well as to adhere now we can also
monitor the risk factors in CLL through
the integration of hematology and the
coagulation ladder so this slide simply
sums up some of the things that we can
look for in the human ecology lab of
course the CBC to monitor the white cell
count as well as the anemia the
differential to look for an abnormality
within those leather sites or to see if
the actual absolute number of
sizes being reduced and then also the
platelet count and this also plays a
part in the in the risk for bleeding in
the coagulation laboratory certainly the
routine coagulation screen that we've
described in terms of the PT and the
appt and then some more specialized
tests such as testing for von Willebrand
factor activity and antigen for those
patients who might develop an acquired
antibody Factory levels for patients who
might develop and acquire hemophilia and
then we can do platelets function
testing through measuring the closure
time as well as platelet aggregate rate
so now turning to one file disorder that
requires immediate attention and this
disorder is called thrombotic
thrombocytopenic purpura
so every move to the thrombotic my
choreographies these actually consist of
two different subtypes thrombotic
thrombocytopenic purpura or TTP and
hemolytic uremic syndrome or hu s both
of these conditions are really very very
similar so it will become very important
to differentiate between the two of
these the characteristics that we see in
patients who present with these two
syndromes would be a micro angiopathy
hemolytic anemia thrombocytopenia and
micro vascular thrombosis as a result of
clot formation in side of these small
capillaries of these patients will
ultimately suffer in organ damage in the
case that we presented you saw that the
patient had a renal failure and she had
damaged into us into the heart and lungs
so a number of organs can be affected
within organ damage
ttp is a rare disorder that's
characterized by microangiopathic
hemolytic anemia if again these patients
will present with moderate to severe
thrombocytopenia the presence of
microscopic clots in the small blood
vessels and it affects about 4 to 6
people out of a million individuals per
year here we have a timeline to show you
some of the some of the discoveries up
with TTP it was first described in 1925
by dr. Eli Moskowitz who described a 16
year old female who pre-poo who died
from a previously undisclosed illness
those characterized by micro angio path
accumulating anemia she presented with
the TTI team of paresis and fever as
well on post-mortem exams it was shown
that she had numerous highland thrombi
that were present in her arterioles and
capillaries and these were present in
the heart and kidneys about 11 years
later barring co-workers described the
highland drum by and suggested that they
can spend consisted of a good native
platelets and then 11 years later singer
and co-workers suggested the term
thrombotic thrombocytopenic purpura
so pgp let's look at the pathogenesis up
in just a little bit we know that it can
we can have what's called a congenital
TTP this is also called the Upshaw
children syndrome and this is
characterized by repeated episodes of
thrombocytopenia and micro mg of mass
accumulate hemolytic anemia that begins
during childhood
TCP can also be acquired and when it's
acquired this is generally due to
antibodies that form against a cleaving
protease this cleaving protease I'll
describe to you is it's actually called
of the one Willebrand factor cleveland
protease or atom TS 13 a dis integrant
and matelo protease would run respondent
type 13 14 if it was actually described
by boy mark in 1982 and he actually
described these unusually large when a
little bread factor multiples in these
patients with TPP and when these
multimers were released he proposed that
there was the absence or a lack of a
cleaving protease that would chop these
multimers up it turns out that these
unusually large running Willebrand
factor multiples of an increased
affinity for binding to platelets so if
you look at the diagram on the right
you'll see a cell here this is the cell
surface with this structure sitting on
the cell surface
that's called atom TS 13 and it looks
like a pair of scissors
so as the unusually large multiples of
one Willebrand factor are being released
this of structural is cleaving protease
proximal chops the multimers into much
smaller pieces so they lose that strong
binding affinity for platelets looking
at the diagram on the far right we see
this is a patient who has a TTP and what
we see here is that the an TS structure
here is defective so we don't have a
scissor mechanism that would cut these
unusually large multimers into smaller
pieces so we end up with these large
multimers that have an increased binding
affinity for platelets leading to
thrombosis now if it's an acquired TTP
and antibody would interfere with the
action of that particular structure what
do these patients look like in the
laboratory when they come in and they
came ecology laboratory the white count
is can vary from normal to abnormal in
this case the white count is normal but
we have a decrease in the red count the
hemoglobin and the humanik right so that
will be consistent with the anemia and
we have thrombocytopenia when we look at
the platelet count in addition if we
look at a peripheral blood smear and
looking at the image of the middle of
this slide we see the presence of
synthesize these fragile RBC's and these
can range anywhere from moderate to
severe in patients with TPP if we look
at the histogram that I have displayed
here and these histograms will vary
depending on the analyzer that's used so
they won't all be the same
but this this is Graham is a little
little special because what it shows you
is a red cell population and the cells
that are falling out of this cluster
would be your fragile lymph us are your
fragile or fragmented RBC's or Shifta
site and the region down at the very
bottom represents platelets now the site
often present a problem in the in the
human ecology laboratory and this is
especially so if we are counting
platelets by obedient by impedance
methodology in this particular histogram
this was counted using optical
technology
and what it does is it shows that there
is a clear separation between the
platelets and the shifter sites so what
this would suggest is that when we're up
when we're counting the platelets there
would be no interference from those
fragmented RBC so we would get a much
more accurate platelet health using
optical methodology now Chicopee can
occur as a congenital disorder as I
mentioned that H us is generally a um an
acquired disorder and on this slide what
we have is another TM a that similar to
TTP in that would be the H us in
addition I have a column year of v.i.c
because we're going to see that some of
our results may look similar between all
three of these so some of the
differences between T V P and H us would
be that TTP is generally a congenital or
can be acquired um
it requires very prompt treatment and
this is generally with plasmapheresis
which replaces the mgs 13 enzyme and in
terms of its prognosis of in the early
days without treatment it was about 90%
fatal but now with the advent of class
or freezes etc of this number has been
greatly reduced the chance of TTP
reoccurring especially if it's a
congenital form of TTP other occurrences
likely when we look at H us of H us is
related to a bacterial toxin this is a
sugar toxin or a sugar life toxin to
late UF is really an acquired phenomenon
and the the bacteria that's been
associated with H us is ecoli o 175 h7
and this bacteria produces a sugar toxin
that causes this damage that's similar
to what we would see in patients with
TTP in addition of
Shigella dysentery has been associated
with this condition is as well now in
terms of treatment rather than
plasmapheresis that would use a TTP in H
us we would treat the underlying illness
so we would get rid of the bacterial
infection and in terms of its prognosis
recurrence is really unlikely the IC can
present somewhat of a similar picture
with the thrombocytopenia and maybe even
some schistocytes etc but the cause of
the IC is variable v IC is associated
with a number of conditions we treat the
IC initially by try we can get rid of
the d IC by really treating the
underlying illness that's causing the d
IC and then the recurrence would be
unlikely
so this table represents some of the
coagulation findings that help us to
distinguish between the TTP hu s and D I
see in patients with TTP the PT and a
PTT are within normal limits the same is
true for patients with hemolytic uremic
syndrome and in patients with VI C the
PT and a PTT are elevated so that's one
of the distinguishing characteristics
between D IC versus TTP and H us with
the d-dimer testing in patients with TC
PNH us the results are normal for
slightly elevated
whereas in di see the results are
generally elevated always when we look
at the fibrinogen assay the value for
the fibrinogen will range from high
normal to increase in patients with TCP
as well as patients with H us however in
di see the fibrinogen level is decreased
so this low fibrinogen would help us to
differentiate di c 12 t GP and h us and
then finally in those patients with
robotic thrombocytopenic such
thrombocytopenia there is a special test
that we can do to identify the level of
adam TS 13 activity this would be the
activity assay and in these patients
it's less than 10% in most of the cases
now there are two additional tests that
we can do along with it with the at MTF
13 activity that would be the inhibitor
level as well as the antibody titer
these two additional assays would be a
reflex testing that would be done but
they would only be indicated in a
patient that had an acquired of TTP as
opposed to a patient with congenital TTP
in the case of H us we can also measure
the level of adam TS 13 activity and in
these patients the level is much higher
than the 10 percent of the inhibitor and
antibody reflex testing would
not be indicated in patients with
hemolytic uremic syndrome and then
finally in patients with D I see these
tests would not really be indicate it at
all but if they were done the results
would be within normal limits
so in summary we reviewed three disease
states who are integrating the results
from the hematology and coagulation
laboratories lead to improve patient
management and outcomes as we can see in
the case of APL the combination of
hematology and coagulation results
supports early treatment of these
patients who present with APL while
waiting for more specialized
conformational tests to be performed as
we can see with CLL the hematology
numerical results that we get from my
analyzer show evidence of lymphocyte
abnormalities that are associated with
this condition in addition the CBC and
coagulation screen can be used to
monitor bleeding risks that we see in
many of these patients and these tests
are very important when it comes to
those patients with a territory related
bleeding case and then finally in those
patients with teaching P even though TTP
is a rare condition the presence of
these RBC fragments that we see on a
peripheral blood smear and the RBC
fragment flag that's available on some
analyzers may provide an indication of
the presence of gtp in these patients in
addition to Tek in addition to looking
for these fragmented red cells we know
that routine coagulation tests that are
combined with and Adam T s13 evaluation
also provides critical differential
diagnosis between TTP hu s and di C
so with that I'll open the floor for
questions
you
Thank You dr. Smith for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the answer question
box located on the far left to your
screen
and we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for so let's
get started
our first question is
are there ways to improve the sharing of
results between coagulation and
hematology when the two labs are not
physically joined together
thank you for that question there are
ways that you can improve sharing the
results when the two laboratories are
not physically located but it would
probably require some type of middleware
such that the people in the on the
hematology side would be able to see the
results simultaneously from the
coagulation side and vice versa that
would probably be the best way to see
the results of course you could see the
results in the lis before you actually
accept it and sent the results off but
that would probably slow the process
down so I would think that a middleware
solution might be a better fit in that
scenario
our next question is WBC is very
important to monitor therapy in this
case as WBC count correct
thank you for your question I think
that's a very good question and
certainly one that we should all look
into I think it may depend on the type
of methodology that you use to counter
WBC's using optical technology I don't
see any problem with the WBC count being
correct as long as it's whipping within
the AMR for the particular analyzer
that's being used with impedance
technology of I'm not really sure but I
can imagine that there might be some
possibility of the of the SI not being
totally correct or the WBC count not
being totally correct especially if
there's some type of interfering
substance that might interfere this
would require that a laboratory would
validate the extremely high counts and
the counts as they return to normal and
make sure that interfering substances do
not interfere with the particular
methodology that they're using
Christmas are there hematology analyzers
that can detect the presence of smudge
cells thank you for your question uh
there aren't some analyzers that may
generate a particular signal of when
they are measuring fluorescence it turns
out that Shifta sites are these fragile
WBC's there has been some association
and if an analyzer is capable of showing
an increase in fluorescence in a
particular cluster population then this
would be possible
I have seen this on some of the optical
analyzers
our next question what role does the
core lab play in patient follow-up after
treatment for any of the diseases
mentioned
the core laboratory played an extremely
important role when it comes to
follow-up if you think about the case of
APL and the increased bleeding risk
certainly the coagulation laboratory
would be able to monitor the
effectiveness of treatment whereby we
would look to see that the values
returned to the normal limits
by the same token the hematology lab
would also play a very significant role
because we could see immediately that
our platelet count is returning to numb
to normal and the elevated WBC count
would be returning back to back to
within the normal limit in the case of
CLL the same would apply we can use the
both the hematology and coagulation
laboratories to monitor improvements in
some of these bleeding abnormalities as
well as the anemia that these patients
presented
dr. Smith are there specific signs that
might help to identify TTP sooner so
that the proper laboratory tests can be
identified sooner that would lead to
earlier patient intervention I thank you
for that question as well there are some
specific things that we can look for
certainly the clinical condition this
patient comes in would be very very
important but in the laboratory itself
the presence of schistocytes is really
very very important and the sooner that
we can identify those schistocytes and
report them out
certainly a physician could start
treatment at a much sooner time point so
if you have an analyzer that can
actually identify these schistocytes
this would be done within a minute of
running the sample this really could
help improve the turnaround time when it
comes to treating these patients
otherwise if you have to depend on a
peripheral blood smear you certainly
have to wait until the smoothness the
slide is made and wait until it's
stained and then for someone to look at
it so by having an analyzer that that's
capable of identifying these fragmented
RBC's that could certainly be very
advantageous
what additional testing would you do in
coagulation to identify acquired von
Willebrand disease to identify acquired
von Willebrand disease we would need to
do some more specialized coagulation
testing such as factories von Willebrand
factor activity and von Willebrand
factor antigen and one of the things
that we would look for would be a
discordant between the levels of them
will grant factor activity and the
antigen in addition there are some
additional tests we could use such as a
mult or multiple analysis etc but to
just get something very quick we could
just simply do a factory button
Willebrand factor activity and bun
Willebrand factor antigen these would be
additional tests in addition to the
routine coagulation tests that we would
normally do
such respect do you need to perform
platelet function studies with the
closure time ompletely at aggregate
gamma trees
simultaneously the you really don't have
to perform both of these as they
simultaneously you may get enough
information from the platelet function
screen depending on what you're actually
looking for either you'll get a
prolongation in your collagen
epinephrine a closure time or your
collagen ATP closure time and this may
be sufficient as long as you're
correlating it with of the patient's
status etc
very often Agri Gamma tree may be done
up but it would require that it be done
right away and so you really couldn't
wait so if you were looking for
something a little more complicated
plated agronomy tree would be your next
choice but I think just a plated
function screen if it's something very
simple that you're looking for
should be sufficient again I would just
re-emphasize that just because the
plated function screen is normal there
still could be a platelet abnormality
that would be identified through
platelet aggregate REE so it really
depends on the clinical condition that
you're looking at and what the patient
is actually presenting with
is APL the only mutation that can occur
in AML if not what are some of the other
mutations and would they respond to
therapy the same way
well APL is only one mutation that can
occur in these subsets of AML and and I
believe that this question may may have
been more focused on the actual mutation
that occurs in ATL's of 1517
translocation this is the most commonly
occurring mutation in APL but there are
some other mutations that can occur and
it is important to understand those
additional mutations because the
treatment would be different the
response that patients of the response
that we get in patients with a 1517
translocation and the therapy that we're
giving them would differ from the
response that we would get if there were
a different type of mutation and the
same thing would occur in see in CLL as
we discussed as well in the deleted 14
affiliated chromosome 13 mutation if
there is a different mutation they these
patients may not respond to therapy very
well so confirming the actual mutations
in any of these hematologic disorders
really is a sensual when it comes to
therapy
and dr. Smith it looks like we have time
for one more question how important is
the routine coagulation screening is
v.i.c
are there other coagulation tests that
can be performed in the core lab to
diagnose di see the routine coagulation
tests are really very simple verb sheep
and they do offer a lot of information
concerning the overall picture the
routine assays that we do for patients
with a DI C of we need to show that
there is this consumption that's
occurring so the routine a PT and a PTT
would be prolonged and that would be
suggestive of consumption the decrease
or in the fibrinogen would go along with
this very same pattern so those are
really very very good on the hematology
side the decrease in the platelet count
would also be very consistent with a di
C there are no specific tests that can
be done that when they are positive it
says I am di C so the routine tests are
really some of the better ones that we
have but most importantly if a
combination of these assays that would
lead to a diagnosis
thank you again dr. Smith do you have
any final comments for our audience I
would just like to wish everyone a happy
laboratory week I hope that you enjoy
many of the festivities that you have
planned and thank you all for listening
to this lecture if you have any
questions please feel free to send an
email we'll try to get back to you as
quickly as we can
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today or those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speakers via
the contact information we provided at
the time of the registration we would
like to thank laberd's and our sponsor
epic Diagnostics authorizing today's
educational webcast this webcast can be
viewed on-demand through November of
2018 labret will alert you via email
when it's available for replays and we
encourage you to show that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live but until next time goodbye